the part that makes me the most sick
about is that our defense played so well
and you say you know you're gonna be in
the Super Bowl and your defense is gonna
hold the New England Patriots to
thirteen points and you guys are gonna
win it's like how and that's the part
that you kind of keep you're playing in
your mind is how that can even happen
Jared Goff the quarterback of the LA
Rams the losers of Super Bowl 53
yesterday we did drafted the worst
quarterback performances of all time in
Super Bowl history golf didn't come up
because we're prisoners in the moment
big cat we assumed that what we just saw
because it wasn't great because we're so
used to great Super Bowls that it was
the worst ever golf was far from the
worst ever
and I think Super Bowl 53 far from the
worst Super Bowl ever we're gonna prove
that now unless of course you pick Super
Bowl 53 is one of your selections the
draft of the worst Super Bowls of all
time pull up the graphic he's called
tails we don't even need to ask him he
always picks tails flip the coin let's
see let's see who's gonna win this
either I'm gonna take it or he's gonna
defer and I'll take it anyway I may have
just I may I should confer there it is
there we go all right why would you
defer because I want the ball in the
second half all right
a Super Bowl was that a real question no
yeah there is no second half so you
should have deferred your last draft
then you would have had the first pick
of this draft
all right Super Bowl twenty nine the
last time the 49ers won a Super Bowl it
was 14 nothing in the first five minutes
nobody thought the Chargers had a chance
in hell to keep up with the 49ers that
was a year where the 49ers were
preordained to win it that was the Steve
Young monkey off the back game they were
their cool shadowed numbers that was
that the 75th anniversary season they
got the dispensation to keep wearing
those they were unstoppable and they
proved that they completely destroyed
the Chargers it was over by the end of
the first quarter it was over by halfway
through the first quarter once I got the
14 nothing in the first five minutes it
was time to go find something else to do
18 and a half point spread never in
doubt
twenty-eight ten and a half like you
said Stan Humphries come on Stan
Humphries it was a Super Bowl
quarterback come on so I only the only
saving grace for this game was Natron
means all time he's in the Hall of Fame
of names
Natron means love that okay my nephew
play hey you remember the chris burrman
nickname eh Ron Natron means business
yeah yeah all right go ahead all right
so I'm not gonna do anything I told you
before the drive I'm not gonna do
anything personal so I'm not gonna put
Super Bowl 41 even though the Bears lost
the Colts I'm not going to pick a Super
Bowl that I wasn't alive for and that I
cannot remember so I'm basically 90 men
on whoa whoa
we you've never seen the endless loop of
the NFL Films half-hour package of the
Super Bowl no I'm doing no what do you
talk it's the action actually it's the
opposite of a cop-out I'm saying I have
to have suffered through this bad Super
Bowl to sit here in front of the
audience that I respect that you
disrespect and say it was a bad Super
Bowl I'm not gonna come here and say oh
well Super Bowl 6 really stunk up
wouldn't have in 1978 or what is 65 when
you were alive but I wasn't okay with
all that said yeah here we go this
entire bit was about making me feel old
no it wasn't you you did this yourself
Super Bowl xxxii Tim hey box 48th
Oakland Raiders 21 also never in doubt
it was known for more off the field than
on the field with the Barret Robbins
stuff you had Jon Gruden and his old
team he knew all the plays he was able
to read everything that the Raiders were
doing and it was never in doubt in a
very boring Super Bowl and I agree with
you and and we've talked about this
yesterday how at one point Tim Brown
suggested that Bill Callahan then the
coach of the Raiders threw the game as a
favor to Jon Gruden because they changed
nothing every of the audibles the calls
Gruden went out and played scout team
quarterback because he knew exactly what
what Rich Gannon was going to do and he
threw five picks three of them returned
for touchdowns it was a disaster it was
horrible
and it was the year after that great
Patriots Rams Super Bowl that that
really spoiled us because it was all the
way down to the wire this thing was over
early that leads to my next pick go
ahead you got something well I was gonna
say it was Rams Titans Patriots Rams
than this and I just wanted to go back
to the start real quickly
you were right we're prisoners in the
moment Super Bowl 53 wasn't great but
people forget how many bet the Super
Bowl used to be the worst game of the
year
it really did when I was growing up in
the 90s he used to be the worst game of
the year we'll get to a couple of those
picks go ahead
well one for me and this was the game
the first Super Bowl played in the 90s
it was a year after that epic
come-from-behind win by the 49ers over
the Bengals the hey there's John Candy
in the front row comment from Joe
Montana and it was like ah this was a
great Super Bowl and and I remember I
was I was in law school at the time and
you know we got all this food together
and this could be a great game and the
Broncos are great now and they're
finally gonna be competitive in a Super
Bowl and you know the 49ers can't keep
winning and something's got to give
between Elway and Montana and it's 55 to
10 and it's like what are you gonna do
with all this food now so I just I have
a vivid recollection of suffering
through that debacle in early 1990 yep
okay I actually remember that game
that's probably one of the first Super
Bowls I remember these two I'm gonna do
two in one pick I'm a cheat you ready
for it yeah Super Bowl 27 in Super Bowl
28 same teams same results Dallas
Cowboys Buffalo Bills this is when I
really started becoming a football fan
and realizing what was going on and my
birthday is right around the Super Bowl
so I always have a big ice-cream cake
that looked like a football and these
Super Bowls were so so bad and this is
what I'm talking about when I say you
know when I was growing up the Super
Bowl was the worst game of the year it
was mostly because of these Cowboys
bills games and the aforementioned 49ers
Chargers game so these games it was sad
Super Bowl 27 Buffalo had nine turnovers
nine turnovers in a Super Bowl Super
Bowl 28 well we all know what happened
oh for four in four straight years
that's maybe the saddest thing ever and
no one likes the Cowboys everyone rooted
against the Cowboys so it was terrible
and and I remember every year like it is
amazing in hindsight that the Buffalo
Bills made it the fourth straight to
lose and keep going back that many years
and to never actually win it it's got
it's got to be one of the most
impressive accomplishments in the
history the NFL
to make it to the Super Bowl four
straight times without ever actually
winning one and the Patriots could make
it to four in a row next year a they've
been there so often like we lose track
like it's just this default the Patriots
are gonna be there and we don't think
there's anything significant about it
because we're numb to it
it's amazing four out of five years and
this this second life they've had ten
years removed from their first Super
Bowl win they've now won three times in
the last what four or five seasons all
right this one for me to the extent
we're gonna make it personal as it
relates to what we actually experienced
I have a vivid recollection in early
1974 and it was right when I was really
like real it like that was a kid and I
had the tops football cards and I had
like the little folder for school with
you know the football players on it I
had the sheets and and and I mean it's
read out like the hook is set now and
the Vikings are in the Superbowl against
the Miami Dolphins the Dolphins have
gone undefeated the year before they
were back in the big game and you know I
I don't know how I became a Vikings fan
but I was and I remember watching the
pregame and they had all these guys
lined up and one guys held the Dolphins
gonna win one guy says the Vikings are
like ten guys and I'd get pissed when
somebody would pick the Dolphins and I'd
get happy when somebody picked the
Vikings and then they started a game and
it was just a complete and total debacle
because the Vikings undersized defensive
line couldn't stop Larry Csonka
who ran through around and over all day
long it was methodical it was boring I
don't know how the Vikings weren't
shutout in that game it was a disgusting
display and I still haven't forgotten it
all these years later did you watch that
on tape delay do they have live super
rules back then that's funny
closed circuit okay we had to go to the
gym at the local YMCA and watch it that
guy the original horns down I like that
oh man that my last pick I almost went
it was Super Bowl xlviii with the
Broncos of the Seahawks but I'm gonna go
with Super Bowl 35 the Ravens 34 the
Giants 7 the Giants only points come on
a kickoff return there was excitement
because it was the most exciting 28 or
whatever it was 36 seconds maybe in
Super Bowl history where you had the
rave
pick six the Giants returned the kick
the Ravens returned the kick that was
very exciting the rest of the game was
terrible
the Giants didn't score an offensive
touchdown that Ravens defense is an
all-time defense it was a terrible
terrible Super Bowl and a little extra
for you Mike who did the Giants beat in
that NFC Championship game forty-one
nothing beat the Vikings that was that
that was the the game where Randy Moss
blew a gasket on the sidelines before
the game and it just all fell apart very
quickly yep I'd rather you know what
though you know what though
that that NFC championship game from the
2000 season that actually hurts far less
than the 98 because the 98 like I had
the full three and a half hour
experience before my heart got ripped
out with 2000 I was asleep by halftime I
said screw this I'm taking a nap this
game's over and the worst worst that
happens is somehow they come back and I
missed it oh well they came back I'll
take it but that was bad that's
conversation for best team all time to
never win a Super Bowl and you know it's
amazing that there's never been a Super
Bowl shutout it's amazing how many close
calls there have been you mentioned that
the Giants only scored on a kickoff
return you take away that kickoff return
they may have not scored a point the the
Super Bowl seven 14-7 the garrow you
Prem e'en ridiculous whatever that was
play that gives Washington a garbage
time touchdown the Vikings get a blocked
punt in Super Bowl nine and lose 16 to 6
otherwise they'd have been shut out they
scored a late touchdown down 24 nothing
to the Dolphins in Super Bowl 8 this
year I was starting to do the research
on the last time there were a shutout in
an NFL championship game because it was
looking like the Patriots had a chance
to shut out the Rams but it's amazing
there hasn't been a shutout and it's
amazing there's been so many that it's
just one little fluke here or there that
allows a team to avoid being the only
team that would have been shutout in the
Super Bowl mm-hmm and Super Bowls are
good again so we should you know we've
had a great run the last decade has been
fantastic I actually read a piece that a
lot of it has to do with the fact that
Super Bowls are now for the most part
played inside domes on synthetic turf so
oh it makes the elements a little less
of a variable and you know this this was
one bad Super Bowl but we've had a bunch
of really good ones the last decade plus
you know here's and let me give you
another theory to back in the 70s and
into the 80s there was a sense that the
team that fell behind in the Super Bowl
early would become mentally broken and
that's just it like whoever scores the
first touchdown wins because the other
team can't deal with this and there's
something to be said for the fact that
now there are so many big games there
are so many big moments there are so
many primetime games where maybe tit
like back in the 70s and 80s whoever saw
these games you saw the highlights at
halftime when Howard Cosell would run
through them there wasn't that same
sense that same magnitude as many times
in the regular season as you would have
and then all of a sudden you get to the
Super Bowl it's like holy crap this is a
big deal and teams would freak out when
they fall behind you don't see that
anymore
that's a good point I I'd agree with
that point there are a ton of big games
every every team that gets to that point
feels like they've been in I don't know
a half a dozen big games in that season
alone the first team that flipped that
was Washington in Super Bowl 22 they
were down 10 nothing after one quarter
to the Broncos and then they exploded in
the second quarter in the 70s and most
of the 80s you're down 10 nothing that's
it it's over you're done you are not
coming back from that because you don't
know how to react in a big spot when
you're behind
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports